il était très attendu par les milieux
associatifs le premier test rapide
d'orientation et de diagnostic du virus
de l'hépatite c a été présenté à la
presse le 12 avril
l'objectif de cet outil élargir et
renforcer le dépistage d'une maladie
souvent méconnue est sous-estimée par
les français le principe c'est tout
simple c'est à partir d'une goutte de
sang au bout du doigt 30 microlitre donc
une toute petite quantité de sang et ben
qu'on va déposer sur ce test est au bout
de 15 minutes
la personne aura le résultat de son test
de dépistage de l'hépatite c
un test disponible à partir du mois de
mai pour les professionnels et les
associations en france ce sont environ
80000 personnes infectées qui ignorent
leur statut
on a des données qui datent de 2004 où
on a montré que la prévalence la
fréquence de l'hépatite c c'était 0 85%
et dont tu eu deux tiers était est et
avait avait du virus dans le sang
donc on pensait aller à l'époque il y
avait à peu près de 230 mille sujets
infectés
ce chiffre a diminué puisque on a traité
des patients entre temps n'at on sait
que ça diminue et les populations dites
un risque qui sont les plus exposés
usagers de drogues personnes transfusées
avant 1992 ou par contamination sexuelle
exceptionnel dans certaines populations
aujourd'hui effectivement on va vers les
publics les plus à risque et on
proposera en même temps qu'on propose du
vih on proposera donc une offre vhc ce
qui va permettre donc aux gens de
pouvoir avoir un vrai dépistage beaucoup
plus complet que ce qu'on proposait
jusqu'à présent l'avantagé du trod c'est
que ça se passe rapidement et puis
effectivement on va pouvoir aller vers
ces populations c'est la spécialité
d'hachette prévention et effectivement
on est en train de cibler des régions
notamment l'ile-de-france où il ya
énormément de personnes contaminées vhc
mais aussi aka languedoc et
nord-pas-de-calais où on avait donc déjà
une forte incidence sur le vih durant la
conférence l'association sos hépatites a
pointé du doigt le fonctionnement du
ministère de la santé
aujourd'hui les coûts de traitement sont
importants puisqu'on considère qu'à et
ce à un traitement c'est à peu près 40
et l'euro pour autant
les coûts étant important le ministère a
décidé de soigner d'abord les personnes
avec des hépatites graves donc en état
de cirrhose ou précis rose le plus gros
du boulot est fait et aujourd'hui il
reste des gens avec des hépatites
minimes qui n'ont pas accès aux
traitements
mais il va falloir revoir le coût des
traitements et l'accès aux traitements
pour tout le monde pour l'association
une solution existe grâce à des
médicaments génériques venus de
l'étranger mais non remboursés par la
sécurité sociale